- [Voiceover] The value of a bond
on January 1st, 2014 is $1,000.
Each year the value of the
bond increases linearly by $75.
So after one year it's gonna be $1,075,
after another year it's gonna be $1,150.
So on and so forth.
Which graph below represents
v, the dollar value
of the bond as a function
of t, the number of years
after January 1st, 2014?
Well there's a couple
ways to think about it.
What's the value of the
bond when t equals zero?
When t equals zero
that means that we are
at January 1st, 2014.
We are no years after January 1st, 2014.
So when t equals zero,
we should get the $1,000
value of our bond.
So let's see, this choice has that.
At t equals zero our bond is worth $1,000.
This one at t equals zero, I don't know,
it doesn't even clear, I don't even
see what the value of the bond is.
So I would rule this one out.
This one at t equals zero the
value of our bond is $1,000.
This one at t equals zero
the value of a bond is $500,
so I would rule this one out as well.
So, the two that we're left
with, this one and this one,
they start in the right place,
but let's see how fast they increase.
So remember, every year we
should be increasing by $75.
Or you could say every two years
we should be increasing by $150.
Or every three years we
should be increasing by $225.
So let's see, here it's, I'm
just gonna try to eyeball it.
Let's see after two years we
should increase by about $150.
And that doesn't look inconsistent
because one whole block
of the vertical access is $500.
So let's think, after three
years we should be $225,
we should be, so that actually
looks a little bit less than
five, a little less than half of $500
so this one is looking pretty good.
Let's look at this choice right over here.
This one's actually a little bit clearer.
It looks like in two years we've increased
almost $500, which means
we're increasing nearly $250 per year.
You see that, in one year we're almost,
looks like we're over, we've
increased by more than $200.
So this one is increasing too fast.
We can rule this one out.
And this one looks close enough.
It looks like it's consistent
with $75 increase per year.
And once again, we're just eyeballing it,
but it looks pretty good.
And this one is way off,
and these two just started
in the wrong place.
So I would definitely go with this one.